[موسيقى]
لا تحتاج
موودل الاختيار الداخلي للجميع
السماء بدورها وهذه هي البطاطا
أمي مينهير كاتب العمود أن البطاطا
دعني انتهي
لا تحاول موديلا وناتشو على الفور
ثم تم سكب صلصة المعكرونة
ولم يتبق لي الكثير علنًا
هذا دبي
البطاطس
حان الوقت لقول ما يكفي من التشجيع أو
marhuanta عجين البطاطس مع التكبير
الرقص سيدتي تحميل النظام الغذائي الخاص بك الأكثر تصويتا
للمهرجين والذهب بعض ما
الحد الأدنى
لهذا هناك المزيد من العاهرات
التحالف مع الضوء يحتاج إلى الكثير
أشياء عن حياته
أفضل بكثير من البطاطس
[موسيقى]
كانت البطاطا للأزمة قواعد tunjo
حتى البطاطس والرياضية
ذات يوم يقتلني
إلى زاويتي
بيريس وياسر لوحدك
الآن لديه نصف الشهرة
زاويتي
[موسيقى]
من الهدف